the leaders building the leaders
building on their productive call in
april and the u.s south africa strategic
dialogue in august will reaffirm the
importance of our enduring partnerships
and discuss opportunities to deepen
cooperation on trade and investment
infrastructure climate and energy and
health we look forward to a productive
visit
president biden's special envoy for the
horn of africa ambassador mike hammer
will travel to ethiopia starting this
weekend to engage on the crisis in
northern ethiopia
special envoy hammer will convey that
all parties should halt military
operations and engage in peace talks he
we condemn
eritrea's re-entry into the conflict the
continuing tplf offensive outside to
gray
and the ethiopian government's
airstrikes
there is no military solution to the
conflict prior to renewed hostilities we
were
encouraged
by five months of humanitarian truce
and are now deeply concerned about the
seizure of humanitarian assistance of
military use all parties should exercise
restraint and we we urge de-escalation
by all actors particularly so that there
can be a re resumption
of humanitarian relief and basic
services to all parties in need
last but not least i also wanted to
share some very sad news to report for
the press team this is the final day of
our good friend and invaluable colleague
alexandra lamanna's detail with us
as you know we have rotating details
from different agencies alexandra
succeeded brittany kaplan at a pivotal
time coming to us from treasury and
taking the lead for the press team on
our response to the supreme court
overturning roe v wade as well as the
ensuing attacks on women's fundamental
rights from elected republicans in
congress and also all over the country
her expertise on economic issues has
also been a huge asset for us in the
press office we're going to miss her
talent her smart her sense of her sense
of strategy
her sense of humor and her work ethic
which speaks to how lucky we have been
to have her on our team we're going to
miss you alex
okay with that
you want to take us away sure um
last night the president said we've
offered every single thing available to
mississippi and the governor has to act
um can you elaborate on that a little
bit what does the president think
governor ruiz has to do now that he has
not yet done regarding the crime so let
me just say a couple of a couple of
things give you give you all an update
so fema administrator deanne criswell is
in jackson mississippi today to assess
the ongoing emergency response
operations
she will be joined by infrastructure
coordinator mitch landrieu and other
federal office officials
i know she will be providing an update
from the ground a little bit later today
fema epa and the u.s army corps of
engineers continue to deploy personnel
to support the state's emergency
response and identify longer-term
solutions to improve the infrastructure
as far as water distribution goes i know
some folks had questions about that fema
has a number of personnel on site in the
state emergency operations center and is
coordinating
with the mississippi emergency
management team to ensure that everyone
has access to water as you know the
president took immediate action to
approve the governor's
emergency declaration request and
directed his team to surge assistance to
mississippi the president and the vice
president both spoke with the mayor of
jackson this week
and that's the that's the update of
where we are again we are determined uh
to to continue to provide all of the the
assistance needed assistance for the
people of the state of mississippi uh
and specifically for the people of
jackson as they go through this uh
really tough time um uh on the ground so
we're gonna continue to do the work but
what did you mean by saying the governor
has to act and so he issued the
emergency declaration obviously but what
more should governor reed be doing that
the white house clearly thinks
i mean as you know there is uh there's
funding that we've provided through the
american rescue plan for upgrades across
the street
across the state which is about 450
million dollars of the city has
allocated 250 20 million dollars pardon
me of its aarp funds for water and sewer
infrastructure needs and there is about
30.9 million through the epa's revolving
loan funds for treatment and
distribution system improvements for
jackson
jackson available right now so the state
has the 75 million this year through the
bipartisan infrastructure law to provide
clean
and safe and safe water this year with a
total of 429 million available to the
state over the next five years
so we're looking across the federal
government to see what else we can do
but you know again this this
administration we're committed uh the
emergency that we're currently seeing in
jackson shows how long deteriorating
water infrastructure can quickly turn
into an emergency as mayor lumumba said
and
this is a result of decades of under
investment
so that is why the president is making
this a priority
so look there's funding there that the
state can tap into for infrastructure
needs a bipartisan
funding law infrastructure law that the
president worked very hard and and
congress did as well to make sure we
deal with these types of long-term
issues
and so we think that you know that
should be happening that should be uh
moving forward and can you talk about
why the president has not spoken
directly with governor reeves at this
point you might be spoken with the mayor
still has the vice president but why is
that communication between put them by
to make governments not happen at this
point i mean look
as i said the fema administrator spoke
to the governor um this week and the
president has spoken to uh
the mayor of jackson uh the
conversations are happening there's
communication as you mentioned in your
question the governor did ask uh first
for our federal assistant took that took
the official uh step doing the
declaration and we responded we surged
the emergency uh emergency funding or
emergency resources i should say
to to the state of mississippi
jacksonville is being specific
in particular because of the urgent need
that they have uh and we'll we'll keep
you abreast if there's any conversation
that is coming in the upcoming days or
and are
you know that that may be happening but
we'll hear from fema administrator later
today uh but right now as you just
stated there's just have not been a call
okay hey grant um the president last
night argued very forcefully that
democracy is under assault but uh what
kind of concrete actions does he
actually plan to take um given that he
described this essentially as a fairly
existential threat to the american
republic so
as as you also heard from the president
yesterday he believes we're at an
inflection point and so uh so that's an
important thing why he wanted to make
sure uh he gave that speech but you also
heard the president express optimism
right about uh the future of america
which was something that was important
for him to deliver uh to the american
people that he believes there's nothing
there's there isn't nothing we can we
can't do right he believes that we can
do everything anything uh as as a
country and and we have seen throughout
our history america has made its
greatest progress out of the darkest
times we see that uh
before one way of course we can do that
is by making our voices heard and he
said that he said that the american
people have a choice
and and but it wasn't just a policy
speech obviously the president believes
that we can make great progress
out of the darkest moments and he calls
on all americans regardless of which
aisle side of the aisle you sit on
regardless which ideology that you may
follow which regardless of the political
persuasion to unite around democracy and
he thought it was an important message
again an inflection point and that was
the message that he delivered again
giving people a choice and saying to
folks we need to come together and make
sure our voices are heard other than
urging americans to vote and make their
voices heard the president has no plan
to confront this
threat that he describes very forcefully
last night i mean it's not the first
time he's confronted
confronted or spoke about this threat uh
he's this is uh he's done it multiple
times at multiple stages uh during the
last three years during his campaign a
couple times as well during
his administration and he'll continue to
to lift that up when he feels it's
needed but what the president did last
night was incredibly powerful it was
clear it was concise it was steadfast
which is uh and he did it a prime time
as you all know uh to the american
people speaking directly to them that
this is a time for us to come together
i'm asking if there's any action behind
these words well the action is making
your voices heard that is a powerful
action we have seen it across time we
have seen it throughout our american
history that making your voices heard
actually can change actually can change
the direction of a country so i would
say that is the most powerful tool that
we have as a country right now and i
know you guys have addressed this to a
certain extent but because you're behind
the podium if you could address the the
criticisms and the questions about why
the president delivered what sounded
very much like a politically charged
speech
as an official white house event
taxpayer funded with two marines in
uniform in particular flanking him
invisible on camera throughout so i'll
take your first question look
the way we see it here
and i would argue the way many americans
across the country see it is standing up
for democracy is not political
denouncing political violence is not
political defending rights
and freedom
is not political making clear that the
challenges
facing the nation is not political we
don't call any of that political we see
that as leadership
and we see that as presidential to your
question about the marines look
the president gave an important speech
last night a critical speech in an added
inflection point
and um you know our democracy our values
of values that our values that our men
and women who protect us every day
and fight for every day
believe in as well
the presence of the marines at the
speech was intended to demonstrate the
deep and abiding respect
the president has for these services
service members uh to these ideals uh
and the unique role our independent
military plays in defending our
democracy no matter which party is in
power again no matter which power
party is in power and
it is not abnormal it is actually normal
for presidents from either side of the
aisle to give speeches in front of
members of the military and including
president donald
ronald reagan
president george h.w bush it is not an
unusual uh uh
site or is not an unusual event to have
happen i'm gonna i'm gonna move around
you've asked three questions no you've
asked you've asked three questions first
question i did no no no i answered the
first question you just
you know i had to just
dive in a little bit more but i
certainly answered it because i said
making your voices heard is a powerful
tool i answered it the first time you
asked i'm gonna go around go ahead nancy
oh thanks so much green um just on the
um treasury department's oil price cap
i'm wondering will the president be
making any personal appeals to world
leaders to jump on this russian oil
price policy so let me just give you a
couple things at the top because this is
a really important first step
and so we're moving from exploring a
price cap on russia oil to gaining an
agreement with g7 nations making up 50
percent of the global economy to
implement one
a global price cap will help us
accomplish our two goals the first one
is significantly reduce putin's biggest
source of revenue for his war chess
number two ensure that oil continues to
flow into the market at lower prices and
supply meets demand the impact of our
efforts to implement a price cap is
already bearing fruit reports show that
russia is already offering steep
discounts as much as 30 percent and
long-term contracts to some countries
this also demonstrates that russia is
planning to continue supplying its oil
and willing to swallow bigger discounts
a price cap will give more countries
better leverage to strike bargain with
deals with russia we will fur will
further work in the coming upcoming
weeks to determine the price cap level
uh release further information including
technical guidance for market
participation and announce our coalition
partners as well a price cap on russia
on russian oil is a powerful tool
one part of the tool
in our agenda to put downward to put
downward pressure on global energy
prices in a way that will benefit
consumers in the u.s and globally and we
are determined to implement this policy
in a way that achieves those goals we're
going to let
folks who are working on this continue
the work this was again a very big step
forward and we'll have more in the
upcoming days as you know this is uh
something that the treasury uh is
leading the u.s treasury is leading but
is the president himself going to ask
world leaders to sign on to this well
here's the thing the president started
this conversation as you know in europe
when we were in germany at the g7 so
this is part of the president's
leadership he moved this forward he
started this uh conversation now the uh
uh
the treasury and our uh
our administration is going to continue
to have those conversations when i will
have more clearly we always share more
if the president's going to put out a
statement we'll let you know
where does the president think the line
should be drawn
for having members of the military
who could be perceived as being part of
stagecraft
for an address
the former president was criticized for
using military many different times in
many different settings and you're right
there have been other instances and
other presidents where members of the
military especially here at the white
house but to be at
a location in pennsylvania where the
marines are not normally stationed where
does the president see the line for
having members of the military included
so
i just want to be very clear you know as
you know the president was at
independence hall uh and you know the
history i'm just gonna i'm gonna repeat
it but i know you know the history which
is where um some of our
some of our the documents of some of our
most critical uh rights and freedoms
were debated uh and uh were drafted and
so
being at independence hall for this
president and you you follow this
president
you know how he thinks and you know uh
how um
you know how he is as an elected
official he believes uh that is
important for him to speak uh very
loudly to have actually the loudest
voice when it comes to our democracy
and so for him this was not a political
speech
this was an opportunity
in prime time to talk directly to the
american people
and to be very clear
clear with a clear voice to talk about
what is happening in our country today
and it was
about our values as a country about our
democracy
as a country and so
that is what the president wanted to
convey
and he believes the men and women who
wear the uniform and protect us every
day protect this country every day
that's what they fight for as well
and so this was an opportunity
as he's having this conversation
leveling right a level conversation with
the american people uh to do that um
so i just want to that's really the the
best way that i can explain how the
president was thinking about this last
night
you know
when it comes to um you know when it
comes to the soul of the nation this is
something that the president has talked
about as i mentioned for years he has
seen
where we are headed
as a country he has been concerned
where our democracy is going
and again he took this opportunity to
directly speak to the american people
understanding understanding that the
marines who are standing behind him
are um
you know are men and women who believe
in our democracy as well who fight for
it every day so
that's um
that's the thinking that i can give you
behind that
on the mississippi issue briefly and
just following up on the other question
is there some
some tension between the president and
governor reeves because this is
obviously an ongoing health concern
day-to-day lifestyle concern a real
crisis for people in mississippi and the
president seemed to be pointed in his
comments there hasn't been leader to
leader
direct communication
is something getting in the way of the
president and the governor speaking to
each other and is that necessary to
further
any assistance or progress on this issue
i mean look it's not necessary to
further any progress in the situation
fema director is on the ground today who
lead who is
uh part of the agencies that that if
anything leads the effort when it comes
to natural disasters that we're seeing
in this case uh it is an infrastructure
issue that we see we're seeing in
jackson mississippi and we're also going
to have we have epa
officials on the ground as well so it's
not necessary to have a leader leader
conversation the federal government is
going to do its job because of the
president has you know has critical when
there's a crisis in a state regardless
of party regardless
regardless of the party you're
absolutely right we've gone to
republican governors who other
republican governors who are in a state
and have delivered emergency assistance
many times sadly during these last 18
months
because
i don't have a call to preview i don't
have
a call to to read out to you at this
time
i can tell you that regardless of a call
the president as i just laid out with an
update
is determined to help uh the people of
mississippi in particular the people of
jackson as they're dealing with this
incredibly tough
time
we have provided funding through
bipartisan infrastructure law we have
provided funding through the american
rescue plan
that is going to we believe
start the process of really dealing with
an infrastructure issue that exists in
jackson mississippi and we have said i
was asked about this yesterday we we are
looking at all options
to ensure that the people of jackson
have access to clean
to clean safe drinking water so that
work is going to continue regardless if
there is a call or not
and because the president he says this
all the time you've heard him say this
he's a he's the president for all
americans and he's going to make sure
that we do everything that we can for
the people in mississippi
okay
yeah thank you thank you karine um i
have a question about uh jackson and
then also just following up on the
speech yesterday um first with jackson
so
fema has uh you've talked a lot about
the infrastructure funding fema
basically has two climate resilience
programs that received a boost from that
infrastructure bill one of them being
brick
jackson hasn't in the past two years
filed applications for that program
still hasn't now has the administration
asked the state whether or not those
applications were blocked or just asked
why those applications haven't gone
through yet so i'll say this
that is a question for fema the fema
director is going to be on the ground
today and i'm sure those many
conversations
will come up about ways that could we
can help
the the city of jackson she's going to
work you all going to hear from her
directly
today so i will leave it to her to
answer that specific question because
you're asking about a specific program
that i clearly don't have
any uh information on it at this time
but you know the fema you know the fema
director director criswell is very good
at her job we have seen what she's
been able to make happen over the last
last 19 months and so we have confidence
that she will get to the bottom and be
as helpful as she can be as we can be on
the ground more broadly just these
smaller poorer communities
tend to not be able to hire the staff
don't have the infrastructure to
actually navigate through this climate
resilience system and get federal
funding often years show this you know
when when you go back and look at
reporting as well so i wonder what what
actual kind of stick does the
administration have to and since so much
of the power is with the states that
this funding actually gets to
communities that need it so um i spoke
to this a little bit yesterday and i'll
talk about it now you know we have put a
real emphasis on making it easier
for state and local government to access
the federal federal savings because
when we talk about the president's
economic plan we talk about lifting
people from the bottom up and and um and
um
out you know out
it is has that in the middle of it
equity and you saw that in his uh
response to also to his um covet
response making sure that equity was at
the center of that and everything that
you see from the american rescue plan
from the bipartisan infrastructure law
for everything that we have dealt with
as we talk about the economy we want to
make sure we do not leave anybody behind
and so
one of the reasons we've asked every
state to appoint a state infrastructure
coordinator
to help streamline communications and
information flow so one of the other
one of the other administration
officials who are on the ground is mitch
landrieu who runs
that team and so he'll be on the ground
he'll be having those conversation and
so having that coordinator is incredibly
important as we engage directly with
against state local governments and
tribal governments as well to help them
quickly assess access the necessary
technical assistance and capacity to
underserved communities to your point so
we have also partnered with
not-for-profits that's another way that
we have found a way to assist
communities in
accessing and deploying these federal
infrastructure funding
including bloomberg philanthropies
immersion collective ford foundation
so and so many more people that we are
partnering with so that folks under in
underserved communities could get that
funding so our goal again is to help uh
local state tribal and territorial
governments
navigate and access and deploy
infrastructure resources that will build
a better community and a better america
so again there's a coordinator that is
connected to getting that bipartisan
infrastructure law
you know you're going to hear from mitch
landrieu you're going to hear from
criswell uh
director kurzweil administrator criswell
who are both down there today and we
will hear a lot more on what we can do
as as an administration and i just have
following the speech yesterday just to
follow up on this point noting that that
rhetoric and delivering speeches can
i i understand the kind of inspiration
the inspirational kind of motivation
factor there um but just frankly can the
american people expect any sort of
policy rollout underlying the speech
yesterday um in the days ahead to
actually address the threat to democracy
look i think
what the president was trying to do at
this moment and we've seen this before
is give americans a choice how do we
move forward
in this time in this inflection point
and one of the ways that we have seen
time and time again in history
is making sure people have their voices
heard
and that comes in many different ways
and he believes as president
it is important for him to be very clear
and direct and to fight the hardest for
our democracy and so that is what you
saw you saw a very strong message from
the president uh it was clear what he
was saying to the american people it's
time uh to to uh you know take a stance
it's time uh to take action
and and we also see that we see that um
polling about what the american people
are anxious about what they care about
is our democracy so it is not unusual it
is something that we have seen over the
last uh several weeks and so you know
the president's going to continue to
have uh those conversations and he's
going to continue to make sure
that
he makes that clear what's the
administration's action besides telling
people to go vote
well
i think we should not underestimate what
that what that can do the power of the
bully pulpit the power of uh the
president and that and that action that
he took last night and what that could
make happen what that the what what that
could lead to and we've seen that in the
past this is not unusual right to have a
a
to have a speech like this and to
encourage uh people to act to send a
message so that uh you know so that the
american people
understand what is happening in this
country and so again the presidency
believes that it is
his job to level with the american
people about threats he sees
to our nation and our values and that's
what you heard from him last night and
we believe it did it indeed resonated
and so again this is something that he's
going to continue to do uh it is a
powerful message that was delivered by
the president i'm going to continue i
have great job
in which the president concludes by
saying vote vote vote inherently
political he wasn't referring to voting
for any candidates he was he wasn't
saying vote for dr oz he was voting he
would say vote uh to reject the the maga
forces i mean isn't that a political
speech
we don't think it's a political speech
when i was here yesterday i actually
said um
that he
would mention voter participation and
getting folks out there to make your
voices heard i said that at the podium
yesterday when i was asked
what this speech was going to be all
about and
look
that is the most powerful tool the most
powerful tool
that americans have is to make sure
their voices are heard it is it is the
most powerful action
that uh an american voter an american
can take and so that is what he is
asking the american people to do i'm
going to continue i'm going to continue
because you're i've asked i've answered
that question a few times
okay go to a different topic we'll get
ahead to the labor day events that the
president has one in pittsburgh one in
milwaukee will the president be speaking
at those events and is he going to be
continuing the message we heard
yesterday or talking more of an economic
theme what what should we expect from
the president on those days and will he
be appearing with the respect of senate
candidates betterment and mandela barnes
in wisconsin so i don't want to get
ahead of what the president's going to
say as you as you uh as you just
mentioned he'll be in
in wisconsin and in pennsylvania on
monday
for the labor day activities that he'll
be participating in i'm sure we will be
hearing from the president don't want to
get ahead of what
he will say
and we'll have more to share on who will
be attending as we normally do i don't
have anything to share at this time
okay go ahead hey great yeah thank you
on social media companies
did the administration give twitter and
facebook uh talking points um over
flagging what the president describes as
misinformation
talk say that one more time has the
administration helped twitter and
facebook with talking points about what
the administration believes is
misinformation or how much coordination
is there between the administration um
and social media companies so i i i
don't have anything to to share with you
on that i'm not going to comment on that
right this time
because the attorney general's from
missouri and uh louisiana said there's a
vast censorship enterprise um across a
multitude of federal agencies yeah i'm
just not going to comment at this time
another topic then um so under this
president under president you saw two
student test scores have come gone
backwards inflation has gone the wrong
direction workers real wages have come
down
um you know we're seeing programs
spending on programs um and promises
that at some point in the future the
transition will be over
what in the last 20 months where's the
progress
so as far as the economy as you know the
jobs report came out today you heard
from the president as he was giving
remarks at his event just now on the
american rescue plan the build back
better challenge uh dealing with 21
cities and you heard from some of the
folks who received the grant today which
is an important
tool it's going to change lives
in in detroit
in greenwood oklahoma in areas that
really need it
and so that is
again another important uh piece of the
american rescue plan that only uh
democratic democrats voted for and also
the american rescue plan helped turn the
economy back on and that's why we have
seen the success of the uh of our
economic success at this past year and
you've asked me this you know i know you
follow economy uh but look but
yes well here let me just talk about let
me talk about the report a little bit
because there's some good stuff in here
uh that kind of touches on what you just
asked me so as you know the good news is
in august the economy created 315 000
jobs which is important we have created
nearly 10 000 million jobs since
president biden took office which is the
fastest job growth in history so you're
asking me where is the success here it
is wait let me finish wait
hold on hold on let me let me let
the share of americans who are working
because that's part of the question that
you just asked me what economists call
the labor force participation rate went
up and that's important and for the
first time working age women this is in
the job report that we just saw today
are now back at work
at rates not seen since before the
pandemic so the bottom line is jobs jobs
are up wages are up people are back to
work and we are seeing some hopeful
signs that inflation may be beginning to
ease we saw that
in july right from july to august we saw
that inflation was starting to ease and
you're talking about education when the
president walked into this
administration schools were closed
businesses were closed and a lot of that
is because we were in the pandemic but
not just that it was so mismanaged by
the last administration that we had to
get to work to make sure that we opened
up the schools which were able to do
nearly all schools were opened in the
first six months
getting small businesses back open
and that was the work that the first new
york that word
that were that was the work
because of this president and democrats
the american rescue plan helped do that
and it was mismanaged what we saw by the
last president what the way that he was
handling the economy the way they were
handling
covid
and getting shots and arms making sure
that people were able to get back to
work that is just a fact and so that is
is there a lot of is there more work to
be done of course to bring down
inflation absolutely that's one of the
reasons the president works so hard to
get the gas prices to come down that's
one of the reasons we work so hard to
get the inflation reduction act so we
can bring down uh cost of prescription
drugs so all of these things took work
and it took leadership all right i'm
going to keep going go ahead
thanks
can you talk a little bit about more
about covid particularly what the white
house is doing to make sure that
congress pay passes the covid uh funding
package
considering last time it didn't work out
so um
so uh
so as you know there remains a pressing
need for additional funding for our kova
19 response in march to your point we
requested that congress provide
supplemental covet 19 funding and
repeatedly warned that without
congressional action we would be forced
to make difficult trade-offs and
reallocate existing funding to meet
pressing needs that is precisely what
happened
the most recently for example because of
congressional inaction the lack of
additional funding has prevented us from
adequately replenishing our national
stockpile
at home the tests which uh
at home test which ends today force us
to suspend sending a free test to
americans and leaves our democracy
domestic testing capacity diminished for
a potential fall surge so while we have
made tremendous progress in our ability
to protect
against and and treat cover 19 we must
stay on our on our front foot and that
requires additional uh resources so the
updating funding request is for 22.4
billion dollars to meet immediate
short-term domestic needs including
testing accelerating the research and
and development of next generation
vaccines and therapeutics prepare for
future variants and support the global
response to cover 19. so again this
funding is vital we're going to continue
to work with congress
we feel that we have the time some time
to make that happen and so
that is uh in order to continue our
progress and build on our progress we're
going to continue to fight for that
funding
that the white house is kind of doing
differently to try to kind of change the
outcome i mean what what makes you think
that there will be a different outcome
so we think that we we think that there
is um uh like last year
we were confident that congress can
reach a funding agreement just like we
did last year
so this is not new and but with one
month until the end of the fiscal year
it's clear that congress
will first need to pass a short-term
continuing resolution to keep the
federal government running and provide
the time needed to reach an agreement on
a fully on a full-year funding bill so
we did it last year uh and so we're
confident that congress could do it
again again steven uh at this hour
there's a report that gina mccarthy the
president's climate advisor is stepping
down is there anything where you can
tell us about
um
yes
she is stepping down gina is uh is is
indeed leaving us she as you know has
been a
a leader in what we have seen as one of
the largest investment
in dealing with climate change
she is a not the first time that she's
been in an administration and we are
very
sad to lose her we will have more to
share i'm sure in the upcoming
and the upcoming
hours
but just to give a little bit of jada
she's a public service has extended
decades across local and state and
federal government including as epa
administrator in the obama biden
administration administration and she
returned she returned to public service
recognizing the unique moment and eager
to support the president at the
beginning of this administration
especially as she sought to launch the
first ever climate policy office and 20
21 plus agency task force to advance a
whole of government approach uh to the
climate uh crisis and so we'll have more
to share but yes that is something that
i can confirm let me ask you about
something else yesterday the defense
department released a pretty disturbing
report on the number of sexual assault
incidents in the military this report
indicated an increase in
particularly female service members who
said that they experienced unwanted
sexual contact and a decrease
in the women who say that they trust the
system to protect their privacy trust
the system to safe insure their safety
and trust the system to treat them with
dignity and respect has the president
been presented with this report and does
he have confidence in the defense
department's leadership to address these
concerns so i can tell you that the
president this is a priority for the
president as you know you've heard from
him
about this before
one sexual assault is one too many and
the president has been clear about
making sure we implement real change
to to rid our ranks of this crime
that is why he signed an executive order
in january 2022 making sexual harassment
a named
military of offense and it's why his
fiscal year 23 budget request proposed
940 million dollars for sexual assault
prevention and response programs
including 479 million and more than 2400
personnel to implement the
recommendations of the independent
review commission and for the first time
in military history beginning in
december of next year investigations and
prosecutions of sexual assault and
harassment will be taken out of the
chain of command and placed in the hands
of the independent special counsel we
understand there's more work to do of
course
as this new data demonstrates but
addressing the scourge of sexual assault
in the military will continue to be a
priority for the department of defense
and this administration we're going to
continue to do the work i'm going to
take i'm going to take one more question
because we actually have to go thank you
i just wanted to follow up on the oil
price cap could you say when that will
be unveiled
so i can say this you know
we believe the price cap will be
successful uh in our goals of
substantially curbing russia's main
source of revenue and lowering energy
costs because it offers multiple ways to
achieve our goals as far as any timing
or timeline as i said moments ago that
this the
u.s treasury will have more on that so i
point you to them but we do believe this
is a an important big step forward
are the main sticking points the closure
of the iaea probe and some kind of
guarantees for foreign companies that if
the us were to leave the deal again
there would be like a wind down period
for contracts so let me just give you a
little bit on
on the status of this
so
you know we have taken deliberate and
principal approach
to these negotiations from the start
and you know if if iran is prepared to
comply
um with this with its commitments under
the 2015 deal then we are prepared to do
the same um and so you know that's going
to be our focus
as it's for as it relates to the iaea
investigations the safeguards our
position is crystal clear iran needs to
answer uh
is chris takeo the investigations are
not political uh they are not leverage
or bargaining chips once the iea
ea director general reports to the board
of governors
that the outstanding issues have been
clarified and resolved we expect them to
come to come off the board's agenda and
not before
we are unbending in our support for the
iaea's independence
there should not be any conditional
conditionality between re-implementation
of the jcpoa and investigations related
to iran's legal obligations under the
non-proliferation treaty and of course
it would be preferable to return to the
jcpoa without any open safeguard issues
the power to achieve that is fully in
iran's hands i'll take one from the back
i'm not sure if i have any more on
ethiopia
president biden laid out last night the
problems that the country is facing
division secretive polarization what is
his message to adversaries around the
world we're looking at this and trying
to leverage the division and in the
country and also allies who are dismayed
at the state of democracy in the u.s so
it's the same message he has sent to the
world since before january 6 about uh
sacrosink's democratic norms and the
importance of standing up for democracy
as authoritarianism rises
around the world and so the same message
nothing is is new this is opposite of
partisan and about uh values much much
bigger uh
much bigger and much higher than that
and that's and that's that's him working
to strengthen democracy
in the world that's what he's going to
continue to do thanks everybody
[Music]
you